What's the only thing we do here, babe?
>> We just We just read.
>> We just read around here, [laughter]
man.
>> It's God. [music]
[singing] It's
God.
It's God. [music and singing]
>> What's going on everybody? Welcome back
to another episode. I'm here with Lady
Logic yet again. And my wife, we got
somebody that actually started to react
to your stuff, man. How you feel?
>> Um, it's fun. Yeah,
>> I like to see their reactions. It's
interesting.
>> Yeah. Some dude named Dr. Nasser, uh
he's a Tik Tocker. Um he does reaction
videos and he uh reacted to the
conversation that you guys did on the
Dr. Dav show. Um you guys could go watch
the original video, the conversation
between four Muslim uh ladies and four
Christian ladies. Um it's blowing up
right now. It's doing awesome. and he
reacted to this and so there was a lot
of backlash. A lot of Muslims did not
like how the Muslim ladies represented
Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Uh [laughter]
that was pretty funny. If you guys want
to check that out, we did a video. That
link will be in the description. So you
excited to see what he has to say?
>> Very.
>> All right. So let's see what what does
Dr. Naser think? Were you guys correct
on the issue? Uh did he think the Muslim
ladies did well? Let's see what he says
here.
>> Do you believe Christians will go to
heaven? I do.
>> Do you guys believe? Yes, we do. The the
Christian who are following their book,
they do the 185 times
>> Allah addresses the believers in the
Quran. He never addresses all Muslims
ever. It's all believers. Believers in
it's an overarching that includes any
believer in the God of Abraham. It's not
Muslims. So when the verse says
believers or Muslims, the word Muslim,
the root of it is submission to God. By
the word Muslim, the book does not mean
Muslim who prays and fast. He means
anybody who submits to God.
>> All right. Uh I can't prove it, but uh I
kind of get a feeling that this fouron
four was kind of a setup. It feels like
the Muslim sisters were told, "Listen,
just show up for a friendly
conversation." Like, "Okay, why not?"
And then the Christians seem like they
came really prepped and ready and
trained for a debate with all sorts of
citations chapter and verse and even
certain numbers of a hadith. Like they
really seem like they came for battle.
So I feel like it was a bit of a setup
and it's a bit unfair. Wow. So listen to
this guys.
Christian women come knowing what
they're talking about. The Muslim women
don't know what they're talking about
when it comes to their own religion. And
therefore, we got to assume that it's
unfair. It was set up um somehow
uh if you're a Christian and you know
Islam and you know the Quran, you know
the Hadith, it's an unfair matchup. Um
dang, baby, what what you got to what
you got to say about that? How did this
was it set up like this? Did it
>> was it was it on fair grounds or what
what how was how did this go,
>> man? Um we all got the prompts in
advance. It was definitely not a setup.
And I think that
>> we did come to have a friendly
conversation.
>> I think if anything in the moments where
it might seem like the Christians are
pressing the Muslim ladies, it's because
we were getting dishonest answers.
>> So, it'll be interesting to see if this
guy thinks that the answers that I
received are honest or dishonest
according to the sources, not according
to feelings. Now, according to the like
where he's watching the conversation,
the conversation was about whether or
not disbelievers go to heaven or hell
according to Islam. If you are a
disbeliever, can you go do you go to
hell? Um, and they were what was their
answer?
>> Their answer was yes. And so I was
asking them cuz um
>> they were saying if you're a believer,
if you're a disbeliever, you still go to
hell in Islam. If you're a Christian or
a Jew or a disbeliever, you can still go
to heaven regardless because being a
Muslim just means submitting to God no
matter who that might be.
>> And what was y'all's retort?
>> Well, one of the Muslim ladies tried to
use 262 to say that Christians and Jews
go to heaven.
>> So, I was asking, how do you reconcile
that with a verse like 385?
>> Yeah.
>> And I wasn't really getting an answer.
So, I was pressing them a bit. How do
you reconcile these verses if that's
your interpretation of 262? What do you
do with 385?
>> Yeah. 385986
that talks about Jews and Christians are
going to be in the hellfire because they
disbelieve. Uh 385 talking about how,
you know, the only religion that Allah
accepts is Islam. So, how do you
reconcile Jews and Christians going to
heaven according to Islam when the Quran
clearly says otherwise in other verses?
>> A lot of other verses. It was funny
because that same Muslim lima told me
not to take one verse out of context.
>> So I was just in the most friendly way I
could saying, "Hey,
>> you guys are taking this one verse out
of context because what are you going to
do with all of the verses that are
explicit,
>> right?" So to be clear, you guys got the
prompts ahead of time, everybody.
>> Yes, we did. That's how I came prepared.
So I got a lot of um love and hate for
having the A hadith number on deck.
Yeah. Yeah. Saying that they knew the
the numbers and the chapter verses and
the name of the hadith. Like it's a it's
a slack against you. But that's that's
really you being ready.
>> I was ready. It was something that I
wanted to talk about and I was hoping to
have an honest, friendly conversation
about it. I never would have expected
the answers that I received. But
>> yeah, not
>> that's the beauty of conversation. You
never know what you're going to get.
>> The Mumboons didn't expect that either.
That's why they up in the in in the war.
All right. So, let's see what else he's
going to say. So, let's see how he's
going to critique this. So he already is
mudd muddying the water. He can't prove
it, but this is a setup. It seems unfair
that the Christian women were prepared
for the discussion and studied the
topics that they were given, but the
Muslim women were not. It's a losing
battle. You're defending Islam. You're
not going to win. Period. It's already
unfair because you're def trying to uh
defend a false religion, a false
position. So it's tough. All right,
let's see what else he has to say. That
being said, let's clarify. Definitely
definitely you have to embrace the
religion of Islam. That is the true
Islam. The prophet says what
I swear by the one who holds Muhammad's
soul in his hands.
He says, "Nobody from this community of
the Jews or the Christians hear about me
and then dies not having believed in
what was sent what I was sent with
except that he will be from the
companions of the fire." So in other
words,
>> so right here he's like he agrees with
Christina and the other ladies. He
agrees with y'all. He's saying y'all was
right. Well, I don't think that the
Muslims from the show would agree with
him because he used a hadith and we
don't know where those come from. We
don't believe them. I think they would
even tell him, hey,
>> you know, be careful. [laughter]
>> Yeah, you can. We don't we don't know if
that is authentic, right?
>> You know, we don't know if that is
authentic.
>> I mean, it's sahi, but we don't know
what that means.
>> We don't know if sahi is sah. If
authentic is authentic, we don't know,
right? And then also on top of that, uh,
if it if it contradicts the Quran, we
throw it out of the sight.
>> Out of the sight.
>> We throw it out of the sight. You
understand? So, yeah, the Muslim ladies
might get on him for this.
>> She would tell him that that contradicts
with 262. [laughter]
>> Sheesh. All right. So, let's see if he
continues. How how you going how you
going to continue?
>> So, in other words, what we believe
about a person who goes to hell is
somebody who is a cafir, someone who is
a disbeliever, someone who rejects the
truth. So if you know the truth of
Islam, if you understand the beauty and
the clarity and the truth of Islam and
then you reject it, then uh you will be
punished for that. And of course, just
logically, why would we go out and
preach to every religion in including
Christians if we thought they were going
to he heaven anyway? It doesn't make any
sense. No, we're preaching to them
because we think they're misguided.
We're trying to bring them to guidance.
Allah says
that Allah says indeed Allah does not
forgive associ association with him but
he forgives what is lesser than that for
whom he wills. In other words, Allah is
saying I don't forgive when you do shik
when you associate partners with me. So
how is it possible that we could worship
a man and then get away with that? No.
Allah says I don't forgive that. Un. So,
this was something that was brought up
in y'all's conversation as well that
they were saying that trinitarians
um that you guys serve the same God, you
know, and so, but Dr. Nasser is saying,
"No, you guys as Christians, you guys
commit sherk with this trinity belief.
You're associating a partner with God."
How do you think the uh how do you think
the sisters would respond to this, man?
The Muslim sisters,
>> I think that they would firmly disagree
with him. I think that they would tell
him that we have a what did they say? a
core or a common share core common.
>> Yes. And that's all that matters. Um
that being a Muslim doesn't mean that
you submit to Allah. It just means that
you submit to God.
>> And so it doesn't matter who it is,
>> right? That makes perfect sense.
Alhamdulillah. [laughter] Alhamdulillah.
Um yeah. So now of course he obviously
misrepresents our faith just by saying
that you know why would we do this and
worship a man and stuff like that when
you got Allah who has hands feet wears
curly hair just know that he's just not
oneeyed all right but he looks exactly
like the djal um but he said something
interesting babe he said that the reason
why we go out and give dollar to Jews
and Christians is because we believe
that they're misguided and and the Quran
is clear that if you're misguided and
you heard of Islam you're going to go to
hell. Allah won't accept you. But
there's something that he's missing.
He's a Muslim,
>> right?
>> He's a Muslim, right? Okay. He's a
Muslim. He doesn't know. It seems that
even as a Muslim, he's deemed to go to
hell. It's decreed that even the Muslims
will go to hell. Now, that's what's the
only thing we do here, babe?
>> We just we just read.
>> We just read around here, [laughter]
babe. We just read. So, let's just open
the Quran up. This is chapter 19. We're
going to read verse 68 to 72. And let's
see if it says exactly what we're
saying. We're just going to read around
here. Let's do this. It says, "Now by
thy Lord we shall surely muster them and
the Satans. Then we shall parade them
about Gehenna hobbling on their knees."
So this the devils, the Satans are going
to go uh to G to Gehenna. That's hell.
Hobbling on their knees. Jesus says,
"Then we shall pluck from every party
whichever of them was the most hardened
in disdain of the all merciful." Then we
shall know very well those most
deserving to burn there. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> No, no confusion on what it's talking
about. Right. Right.
>> All right. Let's see what else he says.
>> Not one of you there is.
>> Not one. Now, how many?
>> Not one. Not one of you there is, but he
shall go down to it, that for your Lord
is a thing decreed determined.
Then we shall deliver those that were
god-fearing, and the evildoers we shall
leave there hobbling on their knees. So
it doesn't matter if you're a Jew, it
don't matter if you're a Christian, it
don't matter if you a Shayan, a jin, it
doesn't matter. Each and every one of
you Muslims, you're going down to hell.
You're going to burn and then Allah
maybe is going to pull you out of hell
determined depending on if you are
God-fearing enough or not. But that the
the rest he's going to leave there to
burn.
>> Now shake logic. I've got a question for
you.
>> Yeah.
Who would try to convince you that if
you believe in him, you're definitely
going to go to hell, but only for a
little while and then he'll get you out?
>> That sound like the devil to me.
Honestly, that's that sounds something
like straight from Satan. I'm not going
to lie to you.
>> Am I Am I hot?
>> Sounds about right to me.
>> Sounds about right. Yeah. [laughter]
Sounds about right. So, it look like we
got we got Satan in disguise again
saying, "Hey, you don't worry about it,
guys. You're Muslims. You're going to be
just fine. You're just going to go to
hell for a little while." um you know,
I'll bail you out.
>> I'll get you out of there eventually.
I'll get you out. See, there is no
reason to be a Muslim.
>> To be a Muslim, you're going to go to
hell regardless if you're a believer or
a disbeliever. It doesn't matter because
it's a matter decreed by Allah. He says
he's going to fill hell up. It doesn't
matter if you're a baby in your loins,
in your father's loins. He created some
for paradise. He created others for
hell. But all of you are going to taste
hell. Every single one of you according
to the Quran. Now according to the
reverse we have the gospel
>> right
>> the gospel what does Jesus say when it
comes to hellfire believers what does he
teach about this
>> Jesus promises us that we will receive
eternal life and that he is preparing a
place for us in his father's house
>> and um it doesn't sound like that place
is hell
>> right Jesus literally says do not be
afraid believe in God believe also in me
he guarantees us He says, "In my
father's house, there are many rooms. If
it were not so, I would I'd not tell you
that I'm going to prepare a place for
you, and I'm going to go away. He's
going to come and take you back to
himself." This is a guarantee that Jesus
gives us when we believe. We have
nothing to fear, right? This is the
opposite of Islam. Islam promises you
hellfire. Jesus promises you salvation.
So to my Muslim friends, me and Lady
Logic, we say, "What you going to do?"
>> Right. Now, imagine if I had brought
that verse to those ladies.
>> Yeah. They would have been like, "You're
you're taking this out of context."
>> Oh, that setup would have been real.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
All right, y'all. With that being said,
man, we appreciate you guys. Hit the
like button. Make sure you hit the
comment section. Check out our other
reaction video that we did. Um reacted
to some of the conversation on the Dr.
Dav show uh featuring Lady Logic and
some other uh hard heavyhitter uh
Christian women who were holding it
down.
>> Shout out to Kalia, Tai, and Chanasa.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Yes, sir. All right,
but that with being said, make sure you
guys subscribe, hit the comment section
what you guys thought about this, y'all
y'all think Dr. Nasa had a point, what
y'all think about the verses we shared,
and do you guys want to see more
reaction videos like this? You guys like
this type of content? Let us know
[music] and we'll pump out some more.
All right, with that being said, we just
got one question for y'all, man.
>> What's the deal?
>> What the deal is?
>> Oh my god.
>> Logic.
[music]